欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课
同学们,第12章我们来讲一下关于如何去做市场分析
快速找到市场的切入口,快速获取商机,达成我们的交易额
在做市场分析的时候,我们很多人都会觉得很难
其实我们是把市场分析这个问题想得太复杂了
总是觉得我们要做市场分析一定要非常非常多的数据才能够去判断
其实不是这样的, 有些行业它本身就没有什么数据, 你只需要根据一些数据就能够看出一些趋势, 同时根据这些趋势去采取一定的行动, 那么我们就能够更加符合这个市场去运作这些店铺, 但是呢很多人以为做市场分析一定需要做很多表格, 其实并不需要什么表格, 只是别人教你的方法都是太过于复杂, 你觉得这些方法太复杂了, 那么你很难去落地执行,
那么你肯定拿不到结果
有些行业的数据很少
你用它们的那些什么复杂的方法
其实对你来说
根本就没有什么大的作用
有些数据很少
那么你看一眼就能够知道是为什么了
为什么我们还要去搞什么数据分析
表格这些呢
另外有很多朋友他不知道在哪里去做市场分析
其实阿里后台就给了我们一个非常详细的板块
就是市场参谋
他已经给我们提供了非常多的数据
只不过是说,我们现在没有思路去应用这个板块, 去把这个板块的数据充分发挥作用, 才会导致我们不知道如何入手, 也会感觉到很难
通过学习后台的一些具体的市场分析的一些思路跟方法, 那么我们也可以利用这些思路方法去分析其他平台的一些情况, 比如说谷歌, 亚马逊等等其他的平台
但是呢, 如果你想做国际站, 最终我们是要以国际站的数据为主, 通过国际站的数据去参考和判断, 其他平台的数据作为辅助
因为在国际站和其他的平台, 他们的人群可能是不一样的, 比如说A产品或者是A品类, 在独立站, 或者是说在亚马逊卖得很好
但是在国际站可能是无人问津的, 甚至有些时候, 你无论怎么样, 国际站上面推广
它都是没有什么效果的
所以我们选择产品的时候
或者是说选择行业的时候
一定要参考国际站的一些数据为主
以国际站的为主
其他的平台的为辅
帮我们去判断
然后我们按照国际站的运营的方法
去操作颠付才行
接下来我们来讲一下
关于市场分析的一个整体思路
我们这里主要是以市场参谋里面的一些板块
跟数据来进行一个分析
和给大家举一些案例
那么这个市场参谋里面会有两个路径
去分析我们的行业
比如说第一个板块就是查行业
这是一条路径
第二个路径是查国家地区
这是第二条路径
那么从查行业这个板块
我们可以看到什么数据呢
第一个就是行业的流量分析
看一下这个行业
它在这个平台上的流量大小
以及流量的发展趋势
第二个就是
这个行业里面的热门品类有哪些, 它的趋势是怎么样的, 这个在后台全部都给我们展示出来了
第三个就是,这个行业里面的这些国家, 是哪些国家更需要这个行业的产品
因为很多时候,不同的国家, 它所需要的行业的产品是不一样的, 所以这个我们一定要重点的关注
第四个呢,买家偏好的产品分析, 也就是很多国家都喜欢同样的一个行业, 但是行业里面是不是会有非常多的产品, A, B, C, D, 这么多类型的产品, 那么不同的国家他们可能喜欢的产品是不一样的, 比如说 A, 美国喜欢, 美国喜欢的 A 产品, B 产品是英国喜欢的, D 产品可能是非洲国家喜欢的,
所以说买家偏好的产品是不一样的,这里我们也可以做一个详细的分析
第五个怎么样去找到有增量的市场
因为有增量的市场说明我们店铺有更大的发展空间和我们店铺的流量会有更大的一个提升的空间
同时呢我们做起来可能竞争度稍微小一点
对于我们的操作跟预算都会有一定的辅助作用
第六我们要通过这个板块的分析来找到我们的精准人群
有利于我们在直通车里面去进行一个精准推广来获得更加精准更加高质量的买家来达成我们的目标
那么这一小节就是关于市场分析的一个整体的思路
我们可以从下面的这六个维度去思考
然后看看我们对应的去查看哪些具体的数据
然后得到结果, 然后根据数据结果, 去分析一下, 接下来要具体操作什么内容, 这样就形成一个完整的链路了, 这节课我们就先讲到这里, 下一节课我们根据查行业, 查国家, 一个个去拆解给大家